Hello!
Welcome back, master!
Howdy!
Howdy doody!
Hi!
It's bloons in time!
Howdy doody!
Howdy!
Why are we saying howdy?
Um... bloons?
Anybody?
Anybody up for a round of bloons?
Yes?
Ice Monkey?
That guy has to be 0-0-0.
So, today I kinda wanna do a challenge where I want to...
I think last time I played, I just got reset.
Recently, kind of over... 100?
Maybe?
Today?
Today we will do 200!
I think.
Um... as you can see, my highest round of all time is 183.
So I'm kinda close.
If anything, I'm kind of a genius.
A veritable cornucopia of games and streamers to watch.
And I'm watching this girl play a flash game...
Hey!
Is it really from E-Bomb's world?
Blueberry...
Seeing as mint is a wall...
Level 200, here we come.
What do you mean by that?
Why am I a wall?
Are you a genius?
Yes.
Absolutely.
Where is Ice Monkey?
He's coming!
Aren't you here for me too?
Or are you only here for Ice Monkey?
Come on.
We'll see Ice Monkey when we see Ice Monkey.
Chibi Minto!
I thought it kind of matched the vibes of this game.
Because I feel like a baby.
Actually, no.
There's a lot of strategy in this game.
Right.
Sniper Monkey is my top monkey.
I didn't know Sato was my top hero though.
Oh, wait.
No, that makes sense.
I use her the most.
I forgot that I...
I got her the skin.
I bought the skin, you guys.
Except, I didn't spend real money.
You don't have to worry about that.
Did you hear Magic Knight Braillers is getting into anime?
I did!
There's like so many.
Also, not only just Magic Knight Braillers.
But also, Rose of Versailles is getting a new movie that's animated by MAPPA.
I'm shocked.
And Ranma!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
It's so crazy.
Let me know.
Is the music too loud?
To me, it feels loud.
Maybe because the song just drives me crazy.
Which one should we do, guys?
Let's do a warm-up or something.
I was playing Bloons earlier.
Bonus rewards?
What kind of bonus?
It's loud?
Oh, okay.
So it's not just me.
Is that better?
The Supai is for Ice Monkey.
I'll pass it along.
This will cover the entire cost for you to buy Killer is Dead on sale in the Steam sale.
I'm bribing you to play a terrible game I love.
What is it?
I'll look it up right now.
Killer is Dead.
I'm looking it up.
I'm looking it up right now.
Thank you.
Kiss.
I just watched the podcast.
It's Tradewinds 2.
The old pirate game you were talking about.
Let me see.
Yo, this game has mixed reviews.
What are you trying to get me to play?
Oh, it's Grasshopper though.
Maddie.
What was I looking up?
Oh, yeah.
Tradewinds.
Hold on.
Tradewinds 2.
It doesn't sound like it, but it might be.
I don't think so.
I remember more of the ships being like a top-down 2D when they're going around.
But it looks kind of similar.
I think.
I think you're on the right path there, David.
Hmm.
Maybe that means someone randomized the order of the reviews.
All Suda51 games have mixed reviews.
Playing Bloons 2 and the overlapping BGMs is a trip.
Well, don't worry.
We'll start right now.
Where are we dropping, boys?
Is this MrBeastMonkey?
Mondozappa, my beloved.
My beloved.
Kill the past.
Play the mediocre.
Yes?
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
You can tell that I'd never have been to this page because I didn't even know that it was called a MrBeastAwesomer pack.
It's $10.
Buy it.
What does it come with?
Exclusive avatar.
And banner for your profile.
10,000 monkey bucks.
Powerful tier 5 insta dart monkey.
Tier 5 insta bomb shooter.
Tier 5...
I never use any of those anyway.
So I don't need them.
I never use them anyway.
Let's go!
I've been trying to...
Let's do this.
We'll do this one on hard.
Right?
MrBeastMonkey.
No!
Is this clash of clans?
Clash of...
Yeah, there's one clan that's the monkey clan and one clan that's the balloon clan.
You know?
We'll do this one on hard.
What I've been trying to do...
Is...
Get my...
These guys...
Oh.
Wait.
Where should I stand?
Where do you guys want me?
Oh.
No, no, no, no.
Where do you guys want me?
Where's the best spot for me?
In the...
In the lake?
I can go right here.
No way!
I'm going to be putting boats here.
I have to go.
At home.
I could be at the house.
I fit right in!
Oh my gosh, I look like I'm from Candy Land right now!
Knock knock!
Minto's home!
Actually, I'm here to sell you something.
At your doorstep.
Open up!
I have real candy!
Never just buy it from me, it's real!
I'll sell you real candy!
You're taller than the house?
Wow, do you want to just not see me at all?
Here, I'll even go smaller.
I can't even... there we go.
Now I can fit through the door.
Perfect!
HOA says you can't keep your creatures outside...
That's rude.
In the loop?
Right here?
But something's gonna go here.
Me!
I go right here.
Oh my gosh!
Me in one loop and Ice Monkey in the other!
It's kind of genius!
Okay, we'll keep it like this for now.
We'll keep it like this for now.
Here, I'm gonna put her right here.
I have unfinished business.
Oh, wow, it's loud.
Hold on.
Whoa, whoa!
Hold on, it's so loud.
You know what?
I don't... she's not as fun as Quincy.
Yes.
I'm doing my part!
Over here.
Yes.
Would you condemn Ice Monkey?
Oh, you're right!
If I put Ice Monkey here, he'll have to work!
Oh, did you guys hear that?
Hi, Paz!
Hi, little baby girl!
What are you doing in here?
You want in my chair?
No, don't plop.
No!
That's my cat.
Let's see.
Who should we...
Sixty days!
Let's hear it for sixty days!
Woohoo!
Sixty days!
That's a long time.
Thank you!
Let's see.
I'm gonna put in a boat monkey.
Right here.
Okay, we'll alternate.
This will be the boat.
This will be the sub.
Ah!
There's a man in my house!
I think we go 0-2-2 made monkey.
Robbery!
Don't look at me like that!
Why are you looking at me like that?
What do you want?
What do you want, little girl?
You're so crazy.
You're just a crazy little girl.
That's my cat.
She's so crazy.
I love her though.
She's so funny.
There's a house around your man.
Oh my god, he's so fast!
Wait, where's the other one?
He's like here?
Ah!
Sorry.
Level up.
How many have you killed?
Oh.
I want to see Ice Monkey juggle.
Where should we put Ice Monkey?
I think we can place Ice Monkey in a good spot that allows for optimal entertainment for everybody.
Oh my gosh, look!
His range is really bad!
If he just stands right here, everyone will be able..
Oh my gosh, you can put him right on the..
What if I put Ice Monkey right underneath me?
Wait, will it look like I'm juggling?
If Ice Monkey is underneath me...
If I'm on top of Ice Monkey...
But then he'll work.
I'll just sell him before any bloop...
Any bloop... Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna juggle!
Watch me juggle!
Isn't that crazy?
The things live 2D can do nowadays.
Just like the thumbnail.
It's true.
I need a monkey asset to put on top.
Okay, Ice Monkey.
I don't want...
I'm juggling!
Crop your head?
Wait, hold on.
You're kind of a genius?
Oh!
I'm the monkey now!
Wait, hold on.
Let me also get rid of the shadow.
For immersion's sake.
Oh my gosh, I look just like this monkey.
Oh, I'm scratching myself!
Eww!
Wait,
hold on.
I think I need to move.
Anybody coming in is gonna be like, where's the streamer at?
So talented.
Watch me do it fast.
Watch.
Are you watching?
I can do it fast.
I can do it slow.
I'm a multi-talented monkey.
I'm not even paying attention.
Don't.
Ice Monkey, no!
That wasn't supposed to happen.
Ice Monkey was supposed to remain pure.
He's not a killer.
Ice Monkey was never supposed to...
Oh, I'm kinda cut off.
Ice Monkey was never supposed to be a killer.
What have you done?
You've tainted Ice Monkey!
Anyway.
I'll stand right here.
You kinda can't see what I'm choosing, but that's okay too.
I'll just explain it with my words.
You enjoy all the monkeying around, don't you?
Let's make a sub...
What are you doing?
Okay.
You have permanently unlocked monkey upgrades.
No!
Wait, what is he talking about?
What are they talking about?
Huh?
I don't understand.
Tutorial jump scare.
Why did that happen?
I should probably start buying things.
Stand on the boat when it gets bigger?
Yeah!
Good idea!
I've never used a single knowledge point before.
Okay!
Uh...
Uh....
Tanjiro!
Most delicious!
Thank you!
Thank you for not looting your phone!
Thank you so much!
I really appreciate it.
Um...
Also I had been leveling up my...
My...
My plain monkey.
In fact we'll put him...
We'll put him in the общormos.
We'll throw him in too.
Put him in coach!
I'm gonna put him down here.
But then I'm gonna buy...
Nice.
More money please!
I should start... I should start doing farms too when I can.
And... I put the shadow because it's kind of hard to see me I feel.
Since I feel like my colors kind of blend in.
So my feet are kind of cut off too.
There we go.
So hopefully it's not too weird though.
It being there.
There we go.
It works well?
That's good.
Now she poops.
Proper ghost aura.
Hokey dokey.
Is that the Minto from Minto Gaming?
Freeze those blue!
No freeze!
He's
not allowed to kill.
He's not a killer.
This monkey has to stand all the way back here.
And juggle.
He's actually... he's actually the...
Oh!
A homeowner.
He owns this home.
Or!
He's the one manning...
No, no.
I like him better here.
He's the homeowner.
Good job Icemonkey.
Keep doing your work.
Keep doing the good work that you do.
I'm gonna do...
Double shock.
He's just chillin'.
Yeah.
Let him stay.
Let him juggle.
And then I'm gonna do the rapid fire.
As you see... As you see...
as you see...
As you can see, I have not touched the middle plane at all, but I'm...
Oh, I can unlock this one.
Oh my gosh, I'm so silly.
I didn't realize.
Nice.
And I can do some of these if I wanted to.
Very large bomb.
I made Ghost Oshie possess innocent ice monkey and turn him into a killer.
BTD6 Light Novel.
Plane's bottom path is the goal?
Oh yeah.
I've been doing this one, like, basically.
It's, like, exclusively.
That's why I have it unlocked first.
Because it's so good.
But I've never...
I haven't... I only did it recently, so I haven't had a chance to try out the most... With this today, we will see what the big plane is.
I'm excited.
I'm so excited.
And then the honing one?
It's just so powerful.
It's such a good... It's a good monkey.
Look at her, though.
She's crap.
I wish there was a good place to put laser monkey here.
Gunner monkey?
Gunner monkey, my beloved.
This guy owns.
Maybe if I, like, stick him and have him go, like, up like that.
You think that will work?
If I put him, like, here and go...
Like that?
Projectile spam makes it look like a Danmaku game.
From one corner to the other diagonal?
Wait, what?
We could honestly have a gunner monkey on every...
We'll put him here.
We'll put him there.
Everywhere.
Anywhere that there's a bit of a straight line.
This one's the longest, though.
And it also reaches the most...
Okay, I think, like, here.
And then, just like...
Yeah!
Right?
That should work.
Just got home to watch the stream.
And at the best part, you place the ice monkey.
Ice monkey's gone!
Rip ice monkey.
Oh no, he's up here.
I forgot that I put him up there.
How you doing up there, ice monkey?
He's like, zero, zero, zero, just as you want it!
He's so right.
I hate this.
Yes.
After I can afford a farm.
Stop bad mouthing, ice monkey.
My bad.
Um, maybe I put him over here.
So typically, I like to put two and two next to each other.
And then, this guy in the middle.
So that he can generate more bananas.
Um, I do sometimes try to do three.
Like, I'll do...
This one, and then this one in the middle.
Because it'll collect the income radius.
And then this one on one... whatever side.
But, I don't think we have room for three.
And also him.
Okay, wait.
We can do one here.
One here.
Then maybe him here.
Maybe?
Hmm.
Bloons tensai.
I prefer banks when there's low space.
Are they smaller?
Is that why it's better?
What type of monkey is the box of bananas?
This one?
But I feel like this one... Okay, correct me if I'm wrong.
I feel like the top route is kind of inconvenient.
Well, until you get monkey wall street.
But also, I feel like... I feel like it just doesn't generate as much bananas as it costs.
Am I wrong?
I feel like there's...
Where is the goat?
Pat?
Fusty.
Top path is best income, but you have to collect it.
Oh really?
So it is actually?
See, but if you have this one, and then this one...
This will just collect it.
Everything in the radius.
So it's really awesome.
That's why you put it in the middle.
But...
But it's so inconvenient having this one.
They cost so much.
It's...
Both of them cost so much.
I mean, all three of them cost so much.
Hmm...
But...
Two banks then?
I like this one too though.
But I guess we don't need...
I like how it generates lives each round too.
I like these two the most.
I'm gonna go with those two.
You guys, I'm a level 180 player.
Okay?
Please understand.
I have experience.
Let's get this one too.
We'll do the...
We'll do...
We'll do the bottom path first.
Because we're gonna have some merchantmen.
I love how well your TV model fits into the game.
It's too cute.
Don't miss any bloons now.
What if I... What if I stand and guard the exit instead?
What if I...
What if I stand and guard the exit instead?
Actually, I'm standing to the side because I'm like Sensei in Blue Archive.
I'm the Sensei to these monkeys.
I tell them what to do.
The last line of defense is Mito.
That's cheating.
How so?
Moab.
How...
How do I live?
Guys, I don't know if we're gonna make it to 200 today.
I mean in this round.
That's okay though.
Oh, another thing I've been trying to upgrade are my...
Are these guys too.
Gran Saboteur.
They did not handle it.
Not at all.
I'll hold off on that.
Until we upgrade these ones.
I'll just hover for now.
Ice Monkey made you live.
You're so right.
Oh, and I gotta get this one too.
It's so good.
Almost.
Yippee!
Okay, now we should be good for a while.
Now we should actually be good for a while.
Oh my god.
They're flying everywhere.
There's just stuff all over the screen.
It's just a warm up round.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
Hahaha.
Alright, I'm gonna change it to the marketplace.
Clear up any monkey... I mean bananas.
Alright.
Let's see.
Who do I want to throw into the ring next?
I'm gonna...
I might actually just add Druid Monkey.
I'm gonna put him up there.
You're probably like, why?
That's such a weird place.
First of all, the guy is gonna have range.
Because he's gonna have...
The Druid of the Jungle.
But also, I need him next to the banks.
Hahaha.
I need him next to the banks.
I mean to the...
Here we go.
Okay, now he's got that good old reach.
Why?
That's such a weird place.
I'm so glad you asked that Sage.
Hahaha.
Mei!
New Bloons DLC with Chibi Minto as new character?
Kawaii!
Hahaha.
I feel like though...
Also, I feel like I would fit into Cookie Run Kingdom even more so.
What do you guys think?
I feel like I'd fit in Cookie Run even more.
Mint cookie.
Hahaha.
Mint chocolate cookie.
Oh my gosh.
Girl Scouts should collab with me.
I basically am the thin mint.
Hahaha.
Or maybe not the thin part.
I'm gonna save up for the laser cannon.
Thick mint.
Hahaha.
Nice.
Good job everybody.
Good job team.
I'm gonna add in another sub.
And another ship.
This ship...
This one will be middle.
Monkey pirate.
This one will be top.
He'll be the flagship.
The carrier.
Chibi Mint fits in any cutesy game.
Oh my gosh.
We won't die this time.
See?
We're all good.
This guy will be...
The sub commander.
What's this one?
Which one should I do?
Allows long range targeting of balloons and radius of your other tower.
This one is so...
The advanced intel is so good, right?
024 glue gunner destroys with SATA.
Trust.
024 glue gunner...
Okay IDK.
Are you sure?
Because your name is IDK.
Do you really trust...
Should I trust someone who doesn't know?
Top path is stronger.
What for the sub?
I already have this...
Oh, wait this one?
The energizer?
I mean...
There you go.
Hahaha.
Don't worry guys.
We'll get to it.
IDK.
Seems a little size.
I'm gonna put him right here.
Next to her.
What was it?
024?
I actually usually do that one.
Actually...
That's usually the one that I go with.
Hey, why aren't you doing your job, idiot?
My bad.
You were trying to do your job.
They were camos.
I knew that.
Nice.
What are we doing?
Oh, this one.
Read SATA.
Level 7 and 11 ability.
I don't read.
This cute TV model makes me want to grab it.
Like that hand grabbing the gerbil rat meme.
Don't grab me, please.
Maybe avoid grabbing the Minto.
With excessive force, okay?
Just saying.
I think you have a problem.
If you're like...
I know cuteness aggression is a thing.
But like...
I'm just saying.
I get so loud!
I'm going to turn it down just a little bit more.
I don't know.
I thought about like...
merch like that.
That would be kind of fun, but I think...
I don't know.
I feel like cookies are pretty easy to ship, right?
Because they're like...
Because they don't really expire so quickly, so...
Get it!
Bloon.
That's right.
I got a good shelf life.
Yeah.
It might crumble during shipping.
That's true.
But like...
If I ship them right, it should be fine.
Actually, I should have put this guy over here.
I should have put this guy up here.
Because then he'll reach even further.
I'm going to sell him.
Hahaha.
Nice.
Good job, everybody.
I'm going to also do our next farm.
Oh my gosh.
Will it fit?
How?
Why?
Oh!
Wait.
Oh my god.
It's still in his range, right?
It's still in his range!
And this one will be a bank.
Oh.
Do they still have the helicopter monkey?
Or upgrade that...
Let's you move monkeys?
Or was that only in four?
Move...
Oh, I don't think so.
Is that a heli...
Is that a helicopter up there?
Or...
That's so nice.
What the heck?
Middle path.
Oh!
It's still a thing.
Oh, I don't think I have that one unlocked.
That's probably why.
I don't have it unlocked.
Maybe quite.
Thanks for the gift.
Okay.
Now I don't have to worry about it.
Let's see.
Where is my heli...
Oh, here.
Oh, wrong one.
Oh, wait.
See, I'm waiting to do this one.
I'm waiting to unlock this one.
But I'm quite far ways away to go.
Hmm.
Batman can move things too.
Wow.
The Chinook.
Blows back more bloons and gains abilities.
Drops lives and cash crates.
And can pick up and redeploy most monkey types.
Oh my god.
What?
Maybe I should unlock them.
Monkey marine!
It's worth?
I haven't been able to get this one either.
I just recently unlocked it.
Maybe I'll go with this one instead.
Okay.
Let's save up for a...
What's the word?
Helicopter monkey.
I need this guy all the way up too though.
Let's see, I'm gonna put it right...
Right next to...
Right next to plane monkey.
This is the airport everybody.
Forgot to use this almost at 3 months.
Thank you Elias!
Thank you!
Wait.
Welcome to Membu's ship but it was retracted.
Who was that?
This one.
Middle path.
But I like the pursuit so I don't have to do anything.
I feel like every path for the helicopter is pretty good.
They each have really good strengths.
If you don't have 1M on round 100ish, I'm leaving but seriously I hope you have a good trip.
1M!
I am 1Minto!
What are you talking about?
I literally have 1M right now.
I'm 1Minto.
I had 1Minto.
I had 1Minto from round 1.
From round 0.
It said most monkey types.
What can it not do?
One order of Minto please.
Hiya Minto.
Hiya Kenny.
Hey there Kenny.
I can't move Ice Monkey.
Oh, temples and air towers.
What does that mean?
What does that even mean?
Who am I teasing?
What's going on?
Are you winning me?
I have an extra life.
Wait, where did that...
I was at like 48.
Where did I get the extra ones from?
Oh, it's from the banana.
Oh.
Laser.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
I love the lasers.
Can you please get the made monkey to negative 1.
Negative 1.
Like intelligence or...
Oh, I forgot to...
Even more.
Stop appearing.
You little freak down there.
Kuma-sama.
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you.
Hi Minto.
Hello.
Jobob.
Alright.
Let's get an aircraft carrier up in here.
We got little planes.
We got big planes.
We got helicopters.
We got planes everywhere.
We got planes in your brains.
Roton 1.
Thank you for the gift.
Oh, she caught me.
I sniped you.
Don't you know...
I have good vision.
Hi ice monkey.
Oh, hello there.
That's probably what ice monkey sounds like.
Kind of like a nerd.
86,000.
It's crazy.
Let's go for the first strike capability next.
So far so good though.
I say.
Until not.
Please upgrade ice monkey.
Must be your first time here.
Hahaha.
What am I looking for?
Oh, this one.
2000.
I'll take it.
We're close.
Yes.
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
Oh, come on.
We're so close.
Look, we're almost at round 80.
I really need to get this guy up too though.
I do.
So he can start giving me more money and more lives.
Pizza!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Ding.
The game your dad played.
The admiral sea battles.
Uh oh.
That was so close.
It's not on same and it is obscure.
I don't think the game my dad played is obscure.
But let me see.
Admiral sea battles.
I think it...
I think so!
Wait a second.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Maybe not.
But it looks very similar.
It looks really, really similar.
There was one thing about the game.
You could go to the towns and stuff.
You could like dock on the ports and like go into town.
So it wasn't always on the sea.
But like the picture frames look so familiar.
Oh my god.
I don't think it is though.
It looks so familiar at first.
Oh my gosh.
It looks so similar.
Almost found it.
Almost.
I almost nailed it.
You really did.
Thank you though, Kevi.
Thank you.
So close.
I like how we'd be beaming up the...
I wonder if it's like...
Why can't he be here?
This is so messed up.
Like not even here.
I wonder if the farm was here though.
If this would still gobble it up.
I'm gonna also get maybe some wizard monkeys.
I feel like we need something in here, right?
Hmm...
Magic monkeys.
Yeah.
I'm trying to also get them up.
So I can unlock this thing.
Something to remove camo.
This one removes it, right?
Well, it's only periodic...
Wait.
Periodically reveals.
Oh, but permanently.
But it's only periodically.
Ah...
Mem... Mem... Mem... Mem...
Hmm...
What do I want to add?
But also, ninja monkeys will strip it, right?
Oh, it can strip the camo.
It doesn't mean it will entirely.
Strong.
We'll do first for that one.
First.
Sticky bomb?
You're a buccaneer for DDTs.
Like...
This is the buccaneer.
Right?
Um...
What?
Nope.
This one.
Sticky bomb?
Okay.
Probably good to have though, right?
Good.
Because they can also attack the...
What's it called?
Um...
The camo bloons.
It's good.
There we go.
Yeah.
Throw your little bombs.
But...
Hmm...
And then I do...
I'll do this one.
There we go.
That should be good.
Oh my god.
0 to 5.
That's what I did.
Maybe I'm getting better at this game.
Oh!
We did it!
Yippee!
All right.
Free play time.
Let's keep going.
You guys.
We're almost to 100.
Which means we're almost halfway to 200.
Okay.
Let's go.
I really want to get this.
Oh!
I really want to get this guy up.
I like him being up so much.
Hmm...
43!
We have quite a few though that...
We just got to keep saving money.
Chopper upgrade.
Oh yeah.
Thank you.
It's so hefty!
Wait, what does the ability do?
Oh, wait.
Blows back many more bloons and gains abilities.
Drops lives and cash crates.
I don't want to... will it always pick them up though?
It drops money and lives.
Oh!
Oh, here's the cash one!
Okay, I see it.
I missed it before.
Here it comes.
Oh, here it comes!
Oh, we got it!
We're slowly but surely getting back to 100.
With sound on, the Oompa Loompa monkeys play music.
What sound?
Oh, this?
Yes?
Wait, why is it...
Why isn't he speaking anymore?
Quincy!
Where are you?
It's because I silenced him for too long.
It means no.
No, I won't take no as an answer!
Quincy, Quincy, are you here?
Oh boy, thanks for the gift!
Quincy, Quincy, speak to me!
Quincy!
I heard it.
I heard him in the... yes?
Quincy!
Quincy, speak to me!
Hold on, you guys, I'm gonna get the Ouija board.
I'm gonna get the Ouija board.
Quincy, are you here?
Quincy, if you're here, give us a sign!
Quincy, give us a sign!
Bunny, welcome to membership, thank you!
Sorry, it's a really tumultuous time right now.
I don't think Quincy's here.
Quincy!
Quincy, are you here?
Quincy, are you alive?
Yes?
Oh my gosh,
the Ouija board always works!
Have you guys ever tried calling me on the Ouija board before?
Rico Mortis has sent in...
No, no, no!
I'm a ghost!
Return to your ancestors.
I don't want to hear you anyway.
It's because... not yet?
Every day?
You don't know my number!
You don't know my number, silly!
You're not gonna know how to contact me!
You're gonna get some random ghosts!
That's bad!
Don't just call people!
Don't just call random people!
Oh my gosh, we're so close!
I just realized how much money we have!
We're doing alright!
When did the DDT start coming in?
I'm scared.
When did we get the DDTs?
So close.
Around 90.
Okay, okay.
Soon then soon.
Is your number 44444444?
No!
A really dumb number to have if you're a ghost!
Because it's so obvious!
If it's... I mean...
What?
Well, I was.
Or actually, I don't know.
What is a ghost anyway?
Here he comes.
Oh my gosh, he looks just like the guys from Outer Wilds!
Thank you for the 44444.
Appreciate it.
I think because I'm a ghost, whatever the gen is, I am that, I think.
Be right back.
Gonna call this ghost number I saw.
No real reason.
So wait, what is it now?
Gen...
Alpha?
Gen Alpha, yeah.
Join us, Zoomers.
You guys are old now.
Zoomers are old now.
It's all about the Alpha, baby.
Oh no, I forgot that I don't have this unlocked.
Oh gosh.
That's okay though.
Which one should...
Wow!
Oh my gosh, that was so close.
That was close.
Let's see.
What should I save up for?
Guys, this Mint will have two number 9s.
Number 9...
Large...
I don't have my piece of paper today.
Also, you have the wrong number!
Mint was here when the Declaration of Independence was news.
I stole the Declaration of Independence.
You guys might not know, but I'm in that movie.
I'm Nicolas Cage.
I'm a millennial and I prefer phone calls.
Texts can be ignored, but the ringing, ringing, ringing will never stop.
Today, I went to go pick up some food.
I didn't realize they were calling me, but I was driving.
I was pulling into the parking lot and they were calling me.
And I was like...
I was like, I have no number calling me.
I'm not going to answer.
I always Google the numbers, you know?
Before I pick up.
And I Googled it and it was the restaurant.
And I was like...
But I was like, I had already parked.
So I was like, if they need me for something, I'll just go inside and I'll see...
I'll see why they're calling me.
And when I went inside...
Oh my gosh, it was like a bunch of teenage girls.
And they were just like...
Why did she pick up?
I kept calling and calling.
They called me twice.
First of all, but I was driving.
And also, I was like...
This is so awkward.
I could never go there again, you guys.
I can never go there again.
They were like...
Who are you?
Or what do you want?
Or rather, they were like...
What do you want to order?
And I was like...
I'm picking up.
And they were like...
What's the name?
And I was like...
Minto?
And they were like...
And they looked at each other and they started giggling.
We tried calling you.
And I was like...
I was...
I was driving!
I can't go there anymore.
I can't go...
I can't...
I can't go there anymore, you guys.
Holy cow, it gives you a lot of lives.
Nice.
Sopping wet cat energy, Minto.
Please help, the ants are descending on my apartment.
What?
Call an exterminator!
Ants...
I once had a sugar ant problem.
When I was a kid.
I caused it.
We...
My...
I was...
I was gifted some...
Like...
Some sugar candies.
Well, I guess candy...
It was...
I don't remember.
It was like some kind of...
Like some kind of rice candy.
And I really liked it.
And...
But I couldn't get it often because...
It was from someone that would like travel.
And...
So I...
Hoarded them.
And...
Then...
And then we got sugar ants.
It was my fault.
My parents were really mad.
They were like...
Why don't you eat the candies?
I was like...
Guys, I'll never...
Because...
Because if I eat them...
I won't be able to have them.
And they're like...
You can't have them anymore now because they're covered in sugar ants.
I really messed up that one, you guys.
I really...
I really messed that up.
I messed that one up.
We made it.
We lived.
I feel like...
Okay.
We need to start getting some other stuff for the DDTs, right?
You messed that one up, chief.
I know.
Oh, this one we can upgrade, though.
And how much money do we...
Oh!
I'll take that.
Nice.
Love how she even bounces just by speaking.
Ba-da-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
It's useless if I still throw him here.
Monkey town.
Ugh...
On what, though?
Hmm...
On everybody?
Everybody gets...
You get monkey-towned!
You get monkey-towned.
Gotta make a move to a town that's ripe for me.
Simba!
Thank you for that.
Thank you for the 15 gift cards.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Appreciate it.
Let's see.
Maybe monkey town here.
If I expand the radius, how far will it go?
Oh.
Oh!
I could have used your ability.
No!
Okay, hold on.
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you!
Big play.
We are so close.
Well, I mean...
Yes, but also so far.
I think... I don't know.
I think I might upgrade laser before I upgrade big play.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Maybe I should just go for the big play.
Apache Dart Ship.
I like that one a lot.
I did go for this one, but maybe I will also do the Apache Dart Ship.
Because that's the one that I have completely upgraded.
Is someone asking about what Ice Monkey is doing up there?
Yeah, he's providing entertainment.
Heisei!
Thank you for the five gifted!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much!
What's going on?
Why?
What's happening?
Why are there so many of the gifted?
Why?
Go on the helipad?
He's going to land on top of me.
I'm going to get crushed.
I'm going to literally die.
Again.
You know what?
Let's just try it.
Even though I'm scared.
Actually, hold on.
If I put it here... See, why can't...
Oh my gosh.
Wait!
I haven't set it down yet!
Guys, this is not good.
This is not good.
I don't
even know if this works.
Oh!
This is good.
I know what I should add.
I should add in some...
Sniper Monkeys.
I'm going to put them here.
Because what I'm going to do...
Is do this.
There we go.
And also, I would like...
I'm trying to decide.
Because I feel like I can put another monkey by the village.
It'll be more worth it.
Because this guy can do this.
Like that.
And make him super duper fast.
I wanted to play monkeys along with you.
But I'm stuck at work for like 24 hours.
Owl, are you okay?
Do you believe that love can balloon on the battlefield?
I'm going to move myself.
I don't like being over here.
I feel lonely.
I'm going to stay right here.
Not so much.
We can keep you company.
Okay.
You better.
I'm holding you to that.
I don't know which one I want to upgrade first.
Actually...
There is the sub 2.
I said I was going to add that sub guy.
And I completely forgot.
That one.
There we go.
This one is like...
Oh my god.
I didn't expect to see so many DDTs.
Upgrade the bank.
But it's like it's alone.
I guess I'll take it.
Oh!
It's this guy.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
This one.
Oh...
I forgot about this guy.
There we go.
We're good.
Yippee!
Round 100.
Easy.
Mostly.
Baby.
I'm going to upgrade this guy.
What is this one doing?
I don't know.
Can I do it again?
Yeah.
I'm going to upgrade this one.
Upgrade.
Oh.
That was it?
Oh my gosh.
But it's such a crazy amount of DDTs.
It's really scary.
Oh my god.
Oh wait.
There we go.
Maybe that will help a little.
Maybe that will help a little bit.
Yeah!
You know what?
Also.
Hold on.
I know what.
I know what one is really, really, really good to have.
And that is...
Hold on.
Let me see.
Uh...
This guy...
No, no, no.
Just kidding.
I'm a liar.
This guy!
He pushes all of them back.
Today is my birthday!
Can I get a Minty Fresh happy birthday song?
Of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Nathaniel.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
So let's get in this guy.
In fact, he should be good here because he'll just...
I think he reaches across the whole map.
He's crazy.
And if he's within range of the town, maybe he'll...
Maybe he'll be able to also do DDTs.
I don't know.
It might be a stretch, but...
Okay.
Now we save up.
Whoa!
My debt is gone!
Yippee!
I forgot about this guy too.
Use IMF loan for more loans.
Alright.
I need more money, you guys.
I need more money.
Oh wait.
I don't want to do the Monkey City.
Which one is this again?
Increases influence...
No, I'm not yet.
No, no.
I think we're okay for now.
Rob your own bank.
Bolts are great for money.
You're right.
You are right.
Let's get ourselves a merchantman.
I'm gonna keep him out of the range.
Well, he doesn't need to be...
Like, this is taking up a spot, right?
Because he...
He can...
Do... guys.
Let's do that.
Whoa!
He looks so cool!
I don't think I've ever seen this one before.
More money!
Yeah!
Whoa!
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
That strike worked so well.
It worked so well.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Do I hate these wands?
I hate them so much.
Woof.
Woof, woof, woof.
Woof, woof, woof, woof, woof.
108.
It is chaotic.
It's absolutely chaotic.
It's chaos everywhere.
Oh my gosh.
Jam, thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you!
Oh, nice.
I'm gonna upgrade with...
You.
Wow!
He's huge!
This poor sub.
Okay.
Easy.
I gotta upgrade this guy too.
But I think maybe Superstorm is our priority.
Or...
Like...
You know.
This guy too.
I don't know.
There's so many!
So many upgrades.
So little time.
And money.
So little money mostly.
Hahaha.
Silver Empress, thanks for the five gifted!
Tac shooters.
See, the thing about my tac shooters is...
This is one, right?
I haven't upgraded them very much.
So it's kind of like...
Not great to have them.
But...
Can I fit more than one?
It won't be like a circle of them, but...
Only one.
No!
So sad.
Have you played around with the Beast Handler?
Just a tiny, tiny bit.
Not a super lot.
But I love that there's dinosaurs.
My favorite part.
Can drag down ZOMGs?
Jeez.
Are they super good?
The Beast Handler?
I don't know.
What update did I miss?
Hahaha.
Welcome to Bloons 2024.
Do I want to keep this guy?
Yeah, I'll keep him.
I'll keep him.
Ice Monkey?
Monkey is carrying hard.
Absolute...
Oh!
Absolutely he is.
Of course he is.
It's Ice Monkey.
Look how cool she looks.
I don't know if you guys noticed, but I got the skin.
She looks so awesome.
Max level.
Look at her.
She's got like an extra hand coming out.
And she and I have the same sleeves.
Yeah.
She looks so cool.
Look how many things are flying around too.
Maybe I should...
Can it fit here?
Now that I think about it.
Uh...
Nope.
I was just going to put them there, but I don't think it'll fit.
Jiangshi Sada is the GOAT.
I know.
She's so cool.
She looks like that Darkstalker's character.
Hahaha.
I know who you're talking about.
I think that's just the aesthetic of like Jiangshi though.
Right?
Hmm.
Sorry.
Hold on.
No.
I'm going to save...
I think I'm going to keep saving up.
A little bit.
Because this is really good.
The Superstorm.
I'm telling you.
It's...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay.
Oh.
We made it through.
Hahaha.
Oh.
I didn't know.
That one was tough.
I feel like I should also upgrade this though.
But no.
No.
It's okay.
Oh.
But I also want to...
No.
It's fine.
I can still do this.
113.
That's right.
You can put the monkeys on the helipad.
I completely forgot.
Thank you for telling me.
These ones.
Yes!
I completely forgot about that.
Who should we put?
We can put Sniper Monkeys.
How are you doing down here, Ninja Monkey?
Are you okay?
I can put another Ninja Monkey.
Maybe like a Grandmaster Ninja Monkey.
An Ice Monkey.
Haha.
Is he going to do it?
Alchemist?
Oh, so he can start throwing things to people?
Might be good actually.
Because he throws...
Right?
The Berserker Brule.
Giving extra damage, range and attack speed.
I think that would be good.
Throw the Ice Monkey.
We have Ice Monkey!
You have Ice Monkey!
Oh, wait.
I don't want to use all my money.
You know what?
I can just go into DEAD!
I CAN GO INTO DEAD!
Hey, are you not throwing anything?
Or what are you doing?
What are you doing, guy?
You're not throwing anything.
Yeah, they're not affected.
He buffs the other towers.
Yeah, but don't they have...
See?
He has a buff.
But this guy doesn't have a buff.
Even though he's in his range.
This one doesn't have a buff.
Do the planes get buffs?
The buffs are not permanent.
Let's see if it shows up.
I guess he had the buff.
And then he lost the buff.
Throw faster!
Throw faster, potion man!
What are you doing?
Oh, it only shows during the round?
No, that's not true at all!
Because... what does this mean then?
Anyway.
You know what?
I don't know anything.
I don't know anything about this game.
I don't know why I act like a genius.
Burn noises.
I'm just going to go into more DEAD.
I'm going to go into more DEAD.
Everybody, we're so close.
I'll feel more safe when we have the super storm.
I know I should upgrade Pirate Lord.
But...
It's fine.
Oh my god!
They're so crazy!
Calm down!
Chill out.
I'm going to give this guy that.
Uh oh!
Cha!
Kiwawa!
Oh, I didn't even use that.
Wow!
The storm is brewing.
Flying fortress is a good one.
What's that one?
What's flying fortress?
Oh, also we have this one I want to save up for today.
Two!
I'm telling you, once we get the ray of doom, it's crazy.
Alright, I'm just going to go for it.
I'm just going to...
Oh no!
No!
There's two of them!
There's three of them!
That was a bad surprise.
Oh my god!
I'm kind of going to die.
Here we go.
See?
It pushes them back!
It's so awesome!
See?
Oh, it feels so good!
Yeah!
Get back to the beginning, you dummies!
Woo!
Nice, nice.
What am I looking at?
Monkey!
Yeah, it's so...
It's so...
It's so strong, I'm telling you.
Now... Oh!
Collect my money.
I'm in debt.
Okay, now we can start upgrading some of these other guys that...
probably have needed it for a while.
But he's just blowing them back.
He's like...
He's like, get to the...
Get to the front of the line!
I was also thinking maybe...
I haven't put in a bomb yet.
Like in a bomb blitz or a moab eliminator.
Might be good or something.
No paragon, you crazy.
I want a paragon.
Oh yeah!
The big plane!
It's a lot of money though.
I feel like...
Yes, I will invest.
But...
Or rather, I'll save up.
But I should get some of these guys higher.
So we feel a little more comfortable.
Oh!
Wait, it's a 5-5-5 tower.
5...
Wait, you can do that?
Wait, is it like...
Wait, no, not you.
No?
Wait, just kidding.
Is it like...
Is it like this guy?
Is this the paragon?
This thing?
I mean, look how much...
Guys, I can barely get to 100,000.
How the hell would I even afford this?
How would I even afford this?
My monkey economy is not really thriving, okay?
We're in struggling times right now.
Let's go into debt!
Yeah!
There's been times though that I've had a lot of monkey money.
I think it was the one game that I got to 183 at.
Half the screen is farms.
Farms do all the damage.
As the bloons go by, it takes their money and it makes them sad and then they pop.
It's really tragic.
Anyway...
I don't think there's much I can do anyway.
Guys, I'm sorry!
Let me let her out.
Let me let my cat out real quick.
I thought she was part of the music.
Let me let you out, baby girl.
Okay.
Alrighty.
It might be stupid to do this, but...
See?
He's blowing them away.
So good.
Just keep on blowing!
Keep on blowing!
Buy a couple more pirate trade ships, maybe?
Yeah...
You're probably right.
And this one, it'll also increase the...
You know what?
This will be a row of pirate ships.
Or...
Merchantmen.
This is our money...
Money row right here.
Money row.
Oh.
I'm out of money.
There we go.
Go!
Nice.
They got lots of money.
Amen.
Hello!
How much
do we have in the bank?
Not so much.
It's kind of OP, isn't it?
It's kind of OP.
This guy, I'm telling you.
He's just like...
You will not pass.
That's literally what he says.
Still haven't even upgraded this guy.
I won't lie.
I've only been watching Ice Monkey juggling.
There he is.
A little silly goofball.
Up there in the corner.
Oop.
More dirt!
Nah, he's pretty cute up there.
He does a good job.
Oh.
126!
One day we'll use an Ice Monkey only map.
Will that make you guys feel better?
DDT incoming.
DDT taken care of.
Yes.
Okay, Ice Monkey only.
How much is an Ice Monkey?
540!
Oh gosh.
Oh gosh!
I was scared for my...
I was scared for my afterlife there.
I was really...
I was really terrified, you guys.
That was dangerous.
That was really dangerous.
I wanna get the bad...
I wanna get the
bad...
Mortar Monkey to strip the reinforced moabs.
See, um...
That's another thing.
I haven't really used the Mortar Monkey very much.
So, um...
I don't have it.
Uh...
Yeah.
So you know, it's just kinda...
It's kinda tough.
We can still use em though.
Camo Bloons pop dirt by flares lose their camouflage permanently.
That's pretty cool.
I see you can see I was working on it.
I was working on it.
Alright Mortar Monkey.
You're gonna go right next to...
No... No.
You're gonna go over here.
Uh... No.
No.
Ice Monkey doesn't need to have hearing...
Dang it.
Damage too, you know.
We can put him right here.
No, no.
We'll put him right here.
Set target.
Yeah, that should be fine.
Thank you!
Ice, ice, ice.
Thank you, Lindrotorelli.
Thank you so much!
Signal flare!
Hey, it doesn't hurt to have him, right?
Yeah, he sets off the fireworks, you guys.
It's his job.
I'm in debt.
We're all good.
This is the color of Ice Monkey.
Please give him a friend.
He prefers to be alone.
This is his friend.
Actually, he's scoping out this house.
So that he can rob it.
Ice Monkey is not a good guy.
But it's okay.
We root for an anti-hero, you know.
Let's see.
Thank
you!
Hooray for debt!
Yippee!
Wait, no!
No, yippee!
Okay, there's DDTs, but we're still okay.
Kind of.
Oh gosh.
Yes.
Reinforcement!
This is not the color of Ice Monkey.
Thank you for the Aqua Super.
Thank you!
Appreciate it.
There's also... Gosh, there's so many things that I want.
There's so many things that I want.
Usually, my Gatlin...
I always call him the Gatlin Monkey.
My... my... my...
Gunner Monkey has like crazy number of kills.
Like this...
Four million...
Thank you for the... Aqua Super, thank you!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Yeah, my Gat... my Gat Monkey.
I should probably pay attention.
I should probably be paying attention.
Look at this.
Four million...
Four million Monk...
Bloons taken out.
I wonder if I should put in...
Not Sniper Monkey.
If I should... I mean...
I recently unlocked the Sun Temple, but I'm too scared to use it.
I'm too scared to use it.
But maybe like a Sun Avatar.
Super Monkey as a... as a treat.
I guess... I think... I don't think it would hurt to have it.
More than anything, you know what I mean?
But I think maybe like here.
Because I think we need more defenses on this end.
And I'm gonna epic range him.
Right?
That's what I usually do.
Yeah.
He's... he's got... he's got the help of the...
Yeah, there we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
And we should soon be able to...
Harness the powers of the...
Of the Sun...
Of the Sun!
I'm never gonna save up enough Monkey Bucks at this point.
At this rate, I'll never have enough money to upgrade my Monkeys.
Yeah!
I think this will help though.
How large is his range?
His range is insane!
Maybe I should have screwed him over a little bit.
Look
at the numbers fly!
Go!
Draw!
Kill!
Yippee!
Number go up.
Number go...
One million.
Two million.
Look!
We've had Sauta the whole time and she's at two million.
Druid Monkey at five million.
This guy is so crazy.
That's why I was like, we gotta get him up there, you know?
Monkey Sub isn't killed very much, but that's okay.
That's fine.
That's alright.
Three million.
Thank you!
Chuu!
Guybrush, thank you!
Think this will help though?
Yeah.
Hahaha.
005 Alchemist is really strong too.
I almost have it.
I think I was working on it.
I was working on it.
As you can see.
It is nice to get the stuff to, you know, get more money.
He's crazy for late game?
I'll add him in then.
I'll put him in like...
Uh...
Hmm...
I really like this mint model.
Credit to the artist.
Thank you!
The artist is Hexose on Twitter.
But their username is like a lot of numbers.
I'll add it to the description.
Oh, I meant to add it to the description of the debut stream.
Put him in the very front, Minto.
Okay!
Hahaha.
I'm gonna put him right here.
Let's check it out.
Let's see how it works out.
He's throwing.
We're generating cash.
We're generating oodles and doodles of cash.
Money.
Good job.
For super late game, he's insane.
Gets 500...
Wait, what?
Whoa!
Gosh.
Oh my gosh.
I never used this enough.
The harpoon thing.
I know it's really good.
I just always forget about it.
I'll be honest.
How much is doodles?
Hmm...
A doodle is priceless.
Can you really put a price on art?
There we go.
I just used it.
Hahaha.
Can you really put a price on art?
How much are you at?
Nice!
Gotta upgrade you too.
Gotta upgrade too many of you.
Look at him!
Okay, I think we really should focus on the plane though.
And if we have to do other things in the middle, we do other things in the middle.
Oh, give me that money.
More money!
You can use numbers or put a little drone to click for you.
A little drone?
Wait, what's that mean?
What do you mean a little drone?
Is there like a monkey that will push buttons for you?
If so, that's awesome.
140 will be the bad damage test.
I'm scared!
Oh gosh!
Maybe we should add more monkeys!
I don't know!
Maybe we should add like another...
Maybe we should do an Apache monkey, you know?
Maybe an Apache monkey.
Hire a real monkey to press it.
Oh, the armored B.A.D.
Oh, that's what she meant!
Oh no!
Oh gosh.
Wait, so that's the...
It has like the little wraps around it, right?
Why can't you be better?
Mortar monkey!
He's like, it's not my fault!
Thank you!
Clockwork, thank you!
It meant, how about some gamer subs?
By using code BOOMER at checkout.
I've had guacamole gamer fart...
What?
And it was good.
Any recommendations?
I've never had that one.
Oh my gosh.
I think I'm gonna have gamer subs for like years.
Because...
I got an email just the other day and it was just like Your gamer subs order has been placed!
And I was like...
Huh?
And they like, gifted me all the new...
All the new stuff!
It's like a scien... they just released like the scientists.
And they gifted me the skateboard and the jacket and everything!
It's everything!
240 super monkeys or whatever is the robo monkey with the village is great damage.
Unless it has changed in the past.
Oh, thanks turtles!
I don't know if my...
Wait, what do I have my...
Oh, go away mortar monkey.
Well, I don't have it up to 4 though.
For the robo monkey.
Are you popping me?
Oh yeah, I'm popping.
140 coming up.
I'm scared!
What do you guys think I should do?
We have the master bomber.
Will that help?
Will that?
Let's see how we do next.
Oh gosh!
It's not looking so good!
Stop it please!
Please!
Oh my goodness.
Middle path alchemist can remove fortifications.
Again?
This guy?
Oh strip!
Oh no, but it's fortified off smaller bloons.
It's not off big bloons.
We need the big, big, big...
We need the biggest bloons.
Hmm...
Then there's also this.
Actually, wizard lord phoenix might be really good to have.
Because we'll have the phoenix out all the time and then we can turn him into a phoenix.
So maybe I should save up for that.
Actually...
Let's collect that money.
2-3 is fine for robo monkey.
I thought it was 2-4.
But the 3 upgrade is decent enough.
As long as you have a village.
They're cheap too.
Hmm...
You can't remove fortified properties from BADs.
Aww...
Phoenix is not good compared to big plane.
Yeah, but it's much cheaper.
I can't afford big plane by...
in 2 rounds.
That's craziness.
I'm going into debt!
I'm dead!
Don't tell the monkeys though.
Oh gosh.
Sell the boats.
Holy moly!
He's worth so much!
He's worth 28,000!
8,000.
Monkeys and radius have increased sale value.
Well that would be why.
You can sell the boats and you get the plane?
Wait.
No?
I don't think so.
8,000?
8,000 is not going to equal to 9,000.
90,000.
But if I sell all 3 of them maybe.
I mean if I sell this one too then yeah.
Okay.
Wait, so it's next round though, right?
I have...wait.
I can do this one and then it's the next one that I play, right?
Okay.
Wait.
Oh no!
I was wrong!
What?
Sell!
I know.
Just cut him up a little bit.
Oh.
Come on.
Come on everybody!
Keep taking him down!
Just a little bit longer.
Stop juggling.
This is not a...
There's the second one!
Can I please?
Um.
Guys.
This isn't looking so good.
Oh no!
Uh.
Oh my god.
Um.
Oh.
I don't even know what to put here.
Goodbye everybody.
Goodbye.
Round 40.
No!
I just got the big play!
What was it?
It wasn't even worth it!
Hahaha.
No!
Oh!
Hohohoi!
Ah.
I blame...
Um.
As a...
Minto who has gotten to level 183 all by myself.
I blame...
Um.
You guys.
No.
I blame...
The monkeys.
They had...
Streaming anxiety.
They...
Performance anxiety.
They have performance anxiety, I believe.
Ah.
I never use these.
Hahaha.
Hmm.
But that's okay.
I ended up...
I still was able to get the thingy, so...
I don't remember what level it was even that I got the...
183 on.
Does it say?
What's that?
Oh.
Sharing.
Total pop count.
Look how many DDTs.
Oh look how much cash I've generated.
Crazy.
Blame going into debt.
Yeah.
Most experienced monkey sniper monkey.
Hahaha.
Insta monkey collection.
33 out of 1400.
Holy moly.
Golden...
I've popped 8 golden bloons.
Ah.
It says on the maps.
I don't see it.
It's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Let's see.
Let's choose one.
Let's choose another.
These ones are pretty cool.
But.
Because I have not reached level 200 by...
By...
At all yet.
I would like to stay on the...
Easier maps.
Just because I will...
Cry.
If it's a harder one.
Cubism is fun.
Yeah I like that one a lot actually.
Kayvar thank you.
If someone were to punt you...
In your chibi model.
How far do you think you would fly?
Asking for science.
With your legs?
I wouldn't even budge.
Don't skip leg day everybody.
Resort?
That's like the easiest one isn't it?
I think we could get to level 200 at resort.
Maybe.
Right?
Let's try it.
I'll even do hard mode though.
I'll do hard mode.
Wait.
Yeah I'll do hard mode.
Still.
Gotta put her there.
Easy mode for easiest?
Nooo.
I wanna reach it.
I wanna reach level 200.
How long have I been streaming for?
Two hours?
I need to make...
You just started.
Yeah I just...
Started.
I will also put in a mortar monkey.
So that we can get more experience for him.
Oh wait.
Close these.
There we go.
Look at the little rockets here.
And of course.
It wouldn't be...
Without our beloved ice monkey.
Relaxing on vacation.
Yeah.
How much is he anyway?
Okay.
810.
I'll put him in next so that he can get lots of experience.
Because...
If we have this one.
What's this one?
Super hot burny stuff that incinerates more...
As long as we get 12,000.
We'll see what happens.
We'll see.
We might not make it.
But that's okay.
He's gonna melt?
Nooo.
No.
He's fine.
Look.
It's chilly.
A little bit.
Beep.
You guys.
Unless I ask for advice.
Please don't spam what I should do.
But I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Ice the monkey.
Oh ice monkey.
The worst part is you're not wrong.
I've got that Slender Man build.
Nice.
Isn't Slender Man like in the sexy...
Tumblr sexy man?
Or am I thinking of the one slur?
They're the same person.
I think.
Oh.
Water monkey.
Sorry ice monkey.
Your vacation...
Is over.
They're doing construction right at the resort.
How terrible.
Just ruined his week.
There was something I wanted to put.
I can't remember what though.
Are you going to recreate that ice monkey?
What's wrong with you guys?
Oh well you're wrong forever.
Fixing to go on a big hiking trip and won't be able to see you for a couple of weeks.
Weeks.
You would...
You...
Weeks.
Have fun.
Good luck.
Don't get lost.
And also don't meet any serial killers.
Unless you are the serial killer.
Good luck.
Don't get caught.
Make sure you clean up the crime scene really well.
Let's see.
Burny stuff.
Nice.
Look at him go.
Don't get caught is good advice for both sides of the serial killer issue.
You know what?
True.
That's actually...
You're actually so right.
I have to touch grass this week.
I don't want to leave my home.
After this stream too, I have a bunch...
Well, not a bunch.
I've been...
Oh!
I forgot that Sara can get the...
Good.
We're fine.
Everything is good.
Also, this is where Gatlinmonkey is so awesome.
I wish I could just put him down here too though, you know?
I have a thing I want to put out.
I want to put on the channel.
Basically, for those who don't know, I will be at a concert on Friday.
If you're going to Anime Expo, the concert is not at Anime Expo, but there's still tickets available.
It's close to Anime Expo.
It's during Anime Expo.
So you can come and see me!
And some other YouTubers!
Like Bao and Meori!
And Utano Pandora!
And we'll be singing!
It's AX adjacent.
Exactly!
So if you're at the convention, you can come see us!
Since you're going to go to Anime Expo in Japan...
Wait, I'm not going to Japan!
I'm going to recommend some anime for you to watch.
No, I'm just going to Anime Expo.
But I don't think I'm going to have time to watch anime.
You can still recommend them, but I don't think I'll have time then.
Take them out!
Signal flare!
What does this do again?
Oh, the camel balloons.
Nice!
Is that the one on NYC?
Anime Expo is in...
LA.
Doki!
Thanks for the ride!
Did you finish Sand Land finally?
Hi Dragoons!
Spank!
Thanks for the tiny gift!
No more sands.
Yippee!
When I came in, you were fighting.
You were like eating.
And then you were fighting a boss.
Then she like rolled you over.
She really took you out.
Oh my gosh.
Bring it back!
Thank you so much for the vending!
Thank you for the vibe!
Thank you!
This map has sand!
Welcome back to Sand Land everybody!
Welcome back to Sand Land!
You can never escape!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you guys for all the gifting!
Thank you!
Thank you Sean!
Thank you Murphy!
Thank you!
You can never leave!
You can never leave the sand!
Something something Star Wars quote.
I hate sand.
It's rough and it's coarse and it...
has cursed my family.
Can we go to the forest land?
I burned the forest land!
The forest!
This is...
Oh hey guys!
Welcome back to Sand Land!
Sand Land!
Tomorrow!
Sand Land the next day!
More and more and more sand!
Sand forever!
Sand always!
Sand I love it!
It gets in my...
my bathing suit.
It gets between my toes.
It's so great!
Sand!
Sand all the time!
Sand in your bed!
Sand in your mouth!
Sand!
Once you're here, you're here forever!
Joy!
Thank you for the gifting!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I should probably start buying some stuff.
Let's start buying some farms.
I'm just gonna start...
Why is it so hard to place these?
Wait, we can give him some shade!
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna strategize this.
One...
Oh come on.
Come on!
Two...
That's all I have.
Down!
Thanks for the donation!
Thank you!
And we're gonna put this guy right here.
It's still in his radar.
It's in his radius, right?
Yeah.
We're playing Bloons.
Which is like a super addictive game.
Oh my gosh.
Bloons is so addictive.
I could play Bloons for...
Forever.
Yeah, Druid is OP.
He's really good.
Where can we buy tickets to the concert?
Let me get the link for you!
Here, I'll just pin it as a tweet.
Or not a tweet.
As a...
Thing.
As a message.
I am performing in a concert on Friday.
Tickets here.
Here.
Paste.
Replace...
Goodbye Ice Monkey.
Goodbye Ice Monkey 000.
Yeah.
Hi Chibi Minto!
Hello!
Nice, nice.
So...
This one will become the merchant.
And this one will become the bank.
And then if we get another one, we can have it be the top one.
Alright.
So this one is the bank.
This one is the merchant.
Both have increased production.
See you in the girls on Friday Minto!
There he gets back!
Oh my gosh, as soon as I get there, I have so many...
I have to sign stuff.
Yurien!
Thank you for that gift!
Thank you for the gifted.
Why are there so many...
There are so many gifted memberships.
Why?
Marketplace.
Wait for the bank.
I have so few monkeys right now.
It's crazy.
But it's okay.
Everyone must become Wisp.
Everybody is MFers.
Oh no!
They're getting loose!
Nice.
Okay.
Now I don't have to worry about it.
Oh!
I have to worry!
Uh oh.
You guys.
I think I have to worry.
Oh, I have no money.
What were you?
What are you good for?
Fire!
Farms!
If you don't...
Restart.
But we can actually upgrade him now.
Yippee!
See?
It wasn't a total loss.
Just a little bit.
I blame Doki.
I was a member for two months and I never noticed.
Wow!
Thank you.
Unless you've been gifted for two months.
And thanks to those people.
Mito, you're embarrassing us.
What?
No!
Wait until Ice Monkey hears about this.
Gosh, why is Ice Monkey so expensive?
In fact, I'm going to start doing this.
Before Ice Monkey makes his little appearance.
See, I like to put these guys on here.
I like to have my sets aesthetically pleasing as well.
You know?
Wait, can I put a...
Wait.
Why am I seeing...
Wait, why am I seeing other...
I think the chat is weird for me.
I think so.
But thank you for all the gifted!
Basically, I see a bunch of people's names.
It's like, so-and-so was gifted...
gifted a membership by so-and-so.
But they're like...
Huh?
I think there's too many gifted memberships.
Guys, I think you broke my chat!
I think you broke my chat!
It's lagging.
What's the backlog?
I'm breaking my chat.
Chill out.
Locked in.
We're gonna have a...
a Gatlin Monkey.
On every corner.
Hey guys!
Thanks for the 20 gifted.
Alright, I know I can put him here.
A Gatlin Monkey.
Gatlin!
He's so slow.
Alright, I'm gonna leave it at this for now.
And I'm gonna upgrade these guys.
And get more farms.
And then, I think we'll be good for now.
I think.
Villar!
Thank you!
Membership.
We're Ice Monkey.
You guys!
I barely have a towel!
Good luck, Charm.
Where was Ice Monkey?
When we were dying, huh?
Where was Ice Monkey before?
Oh wait.
Actually...
Can I fit a village down here?
Hmm...
I don't think I can.
Let's see.
I'm just gonna save up enough until we get it.
Shrapnel.
Oh wait.
No.
That's not saving.
I did it!
I feel like Ice Monkey could use a friend.
Ice Monkey can hire a friend.
When he has enough money, okay?
Ice Monkey mommy is not made of money, okay?
Thank you.
Oh my god.
There he goes.
Yes!
Druid!
You are so OP!
Renting friends.
One's gotta do what one's gotta do, you know?
Okay.
Oh, maybe.
I could maybe fit it.
But I already...
Maybe I need to sell you them.
I like to make them fast and strong, you know?
Ice Monkey friend funds.
Thank you!
Maybe I'll sell him.
Yeah.
It's kind of risky right now.
But if I sell him and move him up a little bit.
Like this.
Then he gets a friend.
They're still like by their towels, you know?
They're still by their towels.
And then...
It'll fit.
See?
Just like that!
Awesome.
And then we can put something over here probably.
Yeah.
Just like that.
Okay.
Oh,
it's like 2,000.
That's okay.
We're not there yet.
And then we'll get this.
Shout out to Ice Monkey!
Yeah!
Jeezy!
Ice Monkey friends funds.
Uh oh.
Oh.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Me saying I wouldn't buy anything else.
Just upgrade the guys that I have.
And...
He'll be fast.
And then...
Oh.
We'll also start adding in some farms.
Come on.
We need to buy a new pair of shoes.
I think he's in radius.
He's in radius.
Okay.
How big is your radius?
He's in radius.
Okay.
This one will be...
Bank.
We need some sort of monkey emote.
Someday.
I will get more emotes.
Nice.
Cool.
We're gonna upgrade what we have right now.
We're gonna work with what we got right now.
Rude radius gets bigger at level 4.
Really?
No way.
Oh.
No.
We did it!
Bye.
At level 40.
This is baby levels, everybody.
Baby levels.
I forgot about you, Gatlin Monkey.
I forgot you were even here.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'll give you some more stuff.
I forgot you were even there, Gatlin Monkey.
He's like, I'm doing my part.
How many have you killed?
Oh.
Actually quite a few.
He's doing his part.
All right.
Can you give the Ice Monkey a 000 attack shooter friend?
Attack shooter?
Attack shooter friend.
Not an Ice Monkey friend.
This.
Okay.
Ice Monkey and his life size attack shooter that they told you not to be afraid of.
That they told you not to be afraid of.
This is the perfect relation.
This is like, you know, when there's people who are just like, I'm in love with the Eiffel Tower.
Like I'm sexually attracted to the Eiffel Tower and I'm going to marry the Eiffel Tower.
Or I'm sexually attracted to my boat.
That's what Ice Monkey is to Tac Shooter.
You know what they say, any hole is a goal.
Precision.
Nice.
And actually I'm going to save up for the bank so I don't have to hover over it anymore.
I'm lazy.
I'm lazy you guys.
What else can we add in here?
I think we should put in... who did we put at the front?
Oh!
Him.
We can put him here.
Yeah.
He will do bottom actually.
It's kind of strange.
But I'm going to do bottom path for him.
So that we can start getting some more money.
More money, money, more...
We're all good.
Easy peasy.
Let's get another farm in here.
This one will be merchant.
Pew!
Stonks for real.
Yes!
What else can we add in here?
Mortar Monkey.
Also we need some boats in here too.
What?
It's also good to have a guy towards the front.
Because the boats can then reach there.
This hole was made for me.
Ice Monkey.
So true Ice Monkey.
Truer words have never been said Monkey.
Wait.
I don't remember how I used to game this part.
I would like put something here and then the rest he...
I cannot remember.
I think I would put the flag...
You know what?
It doesn't really matter.
It's fine.
I'm gonna put this guy in here.
He's gonna be our...
Top route guy.
And I'm gonna put this guy in here.
And he's gonna be our...
Middle route guy.
Very nice.
Alright, let's focus on leveling these guys.
Enzo Mancini.
How do you know about that guy?
How do you know about Enzo Mancini?
If you don't know, basically...
Okay, so there was like this romance novel series about...
Yippee!
About some billionaire guys.
And he was one of them.
He was like the guy.
Enzo Mancini.
And...
Boy golly.
What a series.
Just...
It's about him and his brothers.
And they're all like rich dudes.
Amazon top seller books, of course.
What was it called again?
Oh!
Dirty Sexy Boss!
Is what it was called.
It was the Dirty Sexy Boss.
And he...
Like, it was about this girl who joins this...
This agency and...
I mean...
I'm sure you can infer from the title.
Is the Dirty Sexy Boss single?
No!
Because he's with a girl!
An OL?
Yeah, she was an OL.
I'll be honest.
I don't know why I can't remember.
So I think I just have mentally taken it out.
Of my memory.
It's a big boy.
That was so easy.
We took that big boy out.
I need you to elaborate, please.
Well, I mean...
What else can I say about...
They went on many escapades.
I can't infer from the title.
I remember at one point...
They were like really trying to get this baby company to join in.
And...
It was like drama though.
It was kind of drama.
Because...
The guy like...
Or the baby company...
The guy took over the campaign.
The boss.
Like the head of the company.
Was like...
You can't let a lady take this job.
And...
But the girl.
The main girl.
She's like...
I understand the baby company.
No one understands the baby company like me.
Picasso.
Yeah.
There's something about Picasso.
Oh!
Mortar monkey!
Let's get mortar monkey in here.
I'm sorry.
I must ruin your little date here.
Sorry.
I have to ruin your date here.
But...
It's gaming time.
I've had six babies.
I don't think she has.
Look at...
Mortar monkey is doing nothing.
Come on, mortar monkey.
Do your job.
Maybe I should set him...
Closer.
Come on, mortar monkey.
There we go.
Fireworks for them.
Fireworks!
What was the other thing that generated lives?
Oh!
It was the Chinook, right?
Let's get the airplane in.
I feel like I should...
Okay.
What I'm going to do is...
I'm going to put the airplane and the helicopter both in here.
No.
But I am going to put a village in here.
That's for sure.
That's for certain.
Okay.
I'm going to put it where it is.
Money, please.
Never miss.
Rapid fire.
The Tom Nook.
Oh no.
If I get the Tom Nook, then I'm really in trouble.
Have you guys like played Animal Crossing in the...
I haven't played it in a minute.
Like a long, long time.
I hope my animals are okay.
Okay.
Yeah.
Years ago.
Not since 2020.
Yeah.
And you know what's so interesting too is like for Nintendo Directs, you never hear people being like, new Animal Crossing, please, because it's just so sad that they stopped the updates for Animal Crossing themselves and like the actual game.
It's kind of sad.
It's all about Tomodachi Live.
I think as it went...
What's it called?
Viral.
People are really wanting Tomodachi Live.
Yeah.
I'm a bigger fan of New Leaf.
I think most people are, right?
And then they were just like, yeah, by the way, this is the last update.
And you're like, huh?
Nani?
What do you mean by that?
New Leaf was so great.
I feel like New Horizons was where I suddenly felt no urge to continue.
That's so sad.
Oh.
Okay.
And then if I'm like, oh, I have to work on something, or I have to leave, I can just save it for later.
You know?
It's so nice.
So easy.
Alright, let's throw in some wizard monkeys.
And in fact, I'm just gonna put all three of them right in a row.
They're brothers.
This is the three brothers.
Three brothers!
You... are the...
You are...
You are the guided magic.
You are the fire magic.
You are the intense magic.
But you also all know firewall.
Anyway, play firewall.
And you also know...
This one.
Yes!
Hey, hey, hey!
This is not where you're supposed to put your wall!
What are you doing?
No!
Put it... Oh no!
Oh no!
What the hell?
We messed up!
This brother's gone rogue!
No!
Yippee!
Let's keep going.
He's mad with power!
I know!
It's okay.
Alright, let's see.
What else can we... Let's upgrade this first.
First strike capability.
Because it's really good to have.
More farms.
If you... You guys!
I told you!
Stop backseating!
You convinced me to buy this cursed game and play it.
It's so fun though, actually!
It's not cursed at all!
It's just a tower defense.
What's wrong with that?
What's wrong with tower defense?
How close are we anyway?
Oh, only 8000 experience?
Yikes.
Yeah, it's literally like a dollar to get it anyway.
It's so good.
It's just a good game.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, you... Um...
I'm gonna do this one too.
Do extra damage to ceramic.
We'll just keep it like that for now.
No farms.
Sell them.
Sell all the... Sell all the monkeys to win!
Yeah!
No farms!
No monkeys!
No bloons!
Everybody's dead!
Plants vs.
Zombies.
Also a dollar.
That's a good game too.
So is bloons.
Okay, I wanna get Spectre.
Come on, come on, Spectre!
Come on, Spectre!
Wait, what is this too?
Faster firing magic.
Oh, okay.
I know, I spent money after... Spectre!
Only attack shooter.
So far, things are not so bad.
I like when bloons pop.
I've become obsessed with bloons.
Look, we can all just play bloons together.
See?
Bloons all the time.
Everybody's playing bloons.
Everybody can play bloons.
Everybody!
Everybody can play bloons tomorrow, and then bloons the next day, and then bloons the next day, and then bloons the next day...
And then bloons the next day, and then bloons the next day, and then you're just like, wait!
I mean, doh!
Bloons isn't on the menu!
I was waiting for it!
I'm like...
You are so right!
Bloons!
Didn't realize she had bloons brain rot too.
I think I just like tower defense games, right?
Alright, now...
I'll add in another vibe.
This one will be our top production one.
Oh, I forgot about the DDTs!
Arknights soon.
I heard Arknights is really hard though.
Is that true?
I also used to play a lot of Battle Cats.
The devil on my shoulder is telling me I should play bloons.
The angel is telling me I should play bloons!
It can be difficult.
The hardest stage in the event at the moment.
You know, though... I feel like also...
Blue Archive can be pretty difficult.
I don't think it's just me.
Oh!
Upgrade!
This one!
Sky Shredder!
Nice.
This guy is crazy.
Okay, maybe we should get that.
But first I gotta get the big player, right?
Umm...
I'm seeing what else.
What all we got around here.
What all can be upgraded?
What should be upgraded?
What should we save up for?
What should we...
Oh, sorry.
Ice Monkey, I didn't mean to click on you.
I didn't mean to disturb you.
Blue Archive metacomps are a special kind of hell.
I know!
God...
It's...
Yeah...
For BA, it's just stats though.
I think...
Well, recently I've been like...
Since I've been so behind on...
Like I'm level...
I think I just reached level 73 this morning.
So because I'm behind in levels...
Like I haven't been catching up with the story...
Because I've just been like...
I've just been like...
Focus only on catching up.
Hard to play BA when I stare at the waifus the entire time.
What?
They're so cute when their little TV is running around!
They're so cute!
Love those guys.
Okay...
I'm gonna go for the flagship.
Almost, almost...
Hold, hold...
Oh wait.
I can go into debt.
Yippee!
Ready your Kayoko's.
It's hovercraft Wakamo time.
Hey Mind, it was my 10 year anniversary of my Jeopardy episode airing a week ago!
Oh my god!
Cool Stalker!
Congratulations!
Happy 10 year...
10...
10 years?
Do you feel old?
How do you feel about that?
How do you feel about it being 10 years ago?
I don't know why I'm like...
Oof.
I don't know why I'm acting like it's a big deal.
You're the one who should be like...
Yeah, I feel old.
That's a you.
Yes.
I need a monkey.
I need a monkey!
I'm holding out for a monkey hero tonight!
He's gotta be small and he's gotta be fast and he's gotta eat all the bananas.
I need a monkey!
One second.
Okay, sorry.
We're good.
I need a monkey!
I'm holding out for a monkey hero tonight!
What am I missing?
I mean, I'm missing a lot of things, but...
I'm also just like, what am I missing?
Let's add another...
Add another guy...
In fact...
Okay, hold on.
I said I was gonna put a village here.
Hmm...
I'm trying to decide where I put it because thinking of putting him here...
I don't think he'll get...
He'll reach it though.
Because I want him to be the super storm monkey and then go...
I'll collect that.
Thank you very much.
I do need the preemptive strike tool.
Put him on top of the ship?
Yes.
Wait, can I put this on top of the ship?
No.
I can put him on top of the ship.
That is very true.
Look at him go!
To the right of Saada.
Oh, that's such a good idea actually.
Since he'll blow them all back.
That's a good idea.
Good idea!
Good idea, good idea.
I like...
I like having him like that.
There we go.
Yes!
Oh!
There it is!
Hey, weren't you supposed to strip those guys?
What happened?
What happened, guy?
What happened, monkey?
Uh-oh.
Oh!
I didn't notice the time.
It's fine.
We got this.
We got that easy.
Round 100 done.
Nice.
How can I upgrade here?
Maybe I'll just keep saving.
I'll keep saving up a little bit for now.
I'll keep saving up for now.
How can you expect so much from a little monkey?
They...
They are the ones that put themselves up to the task.
What are you talking about?
It's them!
Oh, let's make him super-duper fast.
We're halfway there.
Wow!
Squidward on a chair!
This map is so easy.
But that's okay.
Steam Summer Sales are so good for PopCap games.
Oh, that's the company that makes this, right?
You're looking extra cute today.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Hahaha.
Let's see.
What was I going to add?
Um...
Oh!
Let's add a...
The helicopter monkey.
I'm gonna put...
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna put this here.
For any other monkeys that will become...
Radius!
And I'm gonna put...
Him.
But...
We're gonna go with...
The Apache.
And for a start...
I'm gonna put...
Oh, why did I grab you?
Does the...
Sorry, I have a stutter.
Does the screen get crunchy?
When there's so many?
Squidward on a chair is the school anthem of the Squidward Community College.
Oh my gosh!
I forgot about my money!
Not so far.
How about now?
Oh my god!
Wait, wait, wait!
Where's my cursor?
We made it!
Oh my god!
That was so scary!
I could've found my cursor!
Maybe it's too little too late, but that scared me.
That really scared me.
That really freaked me out.
I
think I remember having multiple preemptive strikes.
When I... Okay, so it's this guy.
Oh!
Nice!
Or not the preemptive, but the first strike capability.
I'm not gonna upgrade just yet, because I'm gonna get another guy.
That is...
Does that, like so.
And the longer range.
And then...
Yeah.
What's the other one?
Oh, the...
The triple gun.
Oh!
I don't see Ice Monkey.
He's right here!
What are you talking about?
He's been here the whole time.
Oh wait, how's my bank?
Nice, it was almost maxed.
And then...
That one was close.
That one was kinda close.
Yeah, he's just juggling.
He's just hanging out.
Being a little guy.
I'm not gonna upgrade those.
Um, let's see.
Is there anything I can upgrade?
Is there something behind him?
I don't remember.
Nope.
Let's do the druid.
Let's save up for the druid.
My guy!
My mortar guy is not taking out all the little shattering shells.
What are you doing?
Oh, so close!
Wait, am I...
No, I don't have enough.
The menu is accessibility that allows you to turn off effects for most monkeys.
It helps in late game when the screen will freeze from effects.
Ah, thank you!
I think we're good for now.
But I'll keep that in mind for later.
Hahaha!
Oh!
We're so close!
Yes!
Okay, we at least have that guy.
Alright, we're just gonna go into the next one, baby.
Keep on, keep it on!
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice!
Go, go, go!
Seven!
Oh!
My bananas!
Nice!
I'll be honest though, I think this will be...
I'm not...
If I don't make it to 200 in this try...
We will try another day.
And I'll change the thumbnail.
I'll change the...
No.
Actually, I'm gonna say...
I'm gonna change it.
I'm gonna be like...
200 tutorial!
How to make it to level 200 in Bloon's tutorial!
Obviously!
I'm gonna put another guy down here.
Except this guy...
Will be the rocket storm.
Locked and loaded, baby!
Yeah!
Go level 112 or bus!
Hahaha!
What did we make in the...
What did we make it to in the last one?
I don't remember.
140!
Oh, that's right!
The infamous 140!
Infamous 140.
Yeah, yeah.
How could I forget?
TDT's!
There is a...
Why is there a single tac shooter on a chair?
To keep Ice Monkey...
Um...
Company.
They're besties.
They're just keeping each other company.
You know?
As you do.
Why are you putting company in quotes?
No matter what type of company it is, it's still company.
Company is company.
Nice.
I kind of want another...
I want the middle path, maybe.
We can put that one anywhere though, basically.
So I'm gonna put it...
Well, I mean...
You know what I mean.
Actually, we can put like a town right here.
And kind of support some guys down in this area.
So I'm gonna put this guy here.
Well, he doesn't necessarily need to be faster, does he?
But, it's okay.
I'm gonna put some other guys.
I'm gonna put some ninjas down there.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oops.
I messed up the timing.
821!
Welcome to Mambo Shop.
Thank you!
That was a little frightening.
That was a little scary, you guys.
Helicopter's freaking it.
That's why he needs help.
Wait!
This doesn't even fit down here?
Oh, yes it does.
Kind of.
Alright.
Upgrades.
We're going with the middle route.
Middle, middle, middle.
And we'll do...
Which one?
Oh, pursuit.
Pursuit.
There we go.
Okay.
I like to not do anything.
So far, so good.
I heard that.
Grab it.
Oh, there's nothing to grab.
There we go.
Nice.
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
Level 20.
She looks so cool.
I need this guy.
I need this guy up.
Okay.
I need to stop spending useless money, I guess.
I need to make strategic calls.
I have too much performance anxiety.
Tack shooter pop stuff?
How?
Wait, how?
How does...
What?
How has tack shooter pop stuff?
Huh?
Oh, the blimps are fat.
Hahaha.
Oh my gosh.
He's just like, don't worry, ice monkey.
I'll take care of it for you.
Guys, I don't know about...
I don't know about this round.
I don't know.
I'm not feeling it.
Not like this round in particular.
But like this whole...
I don't know how to feel.
Hmm...
Done, done.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Maybe we need... I need another mortar monkey.
In this area.
Set target here.
Like so.
My favorite hero?
Hmm...
I really like sniper monkey.
But I think it's now druid monkey.
He's gotten me out of so...
He's helped me so much.
He gets me money.
He's helped me out of so...
He generates me lives.
Just an all around really pleasant guy.
You know?
In fact, if I put like a glue monkey here.
And then the mortar...
Wait, see why isn't it taking it out?
Is it only for moabs in this?
Well, that's so lame.
Unless I...
Is it...
Once this, will it take it off of the...
Of these guys?
The ZOMGs?
Yeah, but if I put a glue guy here...
It might help it a little bit, I think.
So, glue man.
Glue man.
We're gonna put you right there, buddy.
Glue, glue, glue, glue.
Glue, glue.
It's getting pierce capped.
What's that mean?
So like there's too many other things?
I don't think you can...
Strip fortify it from ZOMGs.
Okay, okay.
If that's the case.
Unless it needs just a little extra...
help, you know?
No, no, no.
No glue gunner.
I've been trying to get the...
I've been trying to unlock this to the bottom for...
You know what?
Let's just stick him in there.
What's it gonna hurt, huh?
Oh, my wallet.
That's what it hurts.
It's okay though.
Why crikey.
Taking out those moabs.
He's slightly British.
He grew up in...
both Australia and in Britain.
There
we go.
Small purchase never hurts.
What do we have?
Oh, what is that?
It's so fast.
Wow.
A power shopper.
Wanted to save up for a druid upgrade.
No, no.
I got the druid upgrade.
Oh, this one.
This one over here.
Yeah, you're right.
You're right.
I messed that one up.
That one is my bad.
It's fine.
Probably.
See?
We're almost halfway there.
We're almost even...
We're almost there.
You know?
We got this.
Actually, I need to upgrade this one.
Well, not anymore.
But you know what I mean.
Handle it.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Took forever.
Oh god.
Yeah, we're gonna get this guy up.
Before 140 maybe.
Who knows actually.
At this rate...
Who knows.
This is not optimal.
Even for my standards.
But...
We could sell a few things.
I could honestly sell this for now.
But other things I must keep around.
We have Ice Monkey!
True!
True.
We must believe.
We have Ice Monkey.
I don't even have these guys maxed.
Maybe it's because I've been playing on hard.
I think I got to the 183 on...
Not easy, on normal.
I think so.
I might just need to put a glue gunner up here too.
It really does help.
But it really helps around this part because...
There's just a lot of good stuff over here.
Yeah!
Glue gunner!
You know what?
Let's max upgrade him even.
Yeah!
Glue his base.
I think, yeah.
It was something that I did not appreciate enough...
Until...
Until later on.
Druid 2 never be maxed.
Shhh!
I'll get there!
Just you wait.
What if I put a...
Can I put...
Oh my gosh!
It's kind of fun.
Having some...
Having these two up on here.
No, no, no.
I have to save.
I have to save money!
I don't think he even does anything against the BADs.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
Thank you.
Druid will never level 2.
No!
Look at this!
It's so great!
They just kind of stay there in place.
They're just chilling.
Have you considered putting the Druid attack speed boosters by the Superstorm once you get them?
Wait, what do you...
What do you mean?
Druid attack speed...
This one?
No.
This is the guy that goes crazy.
Is there like a sub-skill of this guy?
Or...
Is the bottom Druid...
Is the bottom Druid... It is?
Boost attack...
Oh!
Oh, we can!
I was about to put him down.
I'd be like...
We'll just add him now!
134, everybody!
134!
Pop lust!
We're half!
Yes!
Squidward on a chair!
Trying to get side by...
This is great!
Maybe I should put another glue guy here.
He'll glue all of them up.
Once they pop too.
Okay guys, hold on.
Don't judge me.
I'm just saying.
Wait, should he go here?
Yeah, he can reach.
He can reach.
Well...
Maybe... Hold on.
Where does this one reach?
This one reached in the bottom?
Kind of?
No!
I'm just...
Okay.
I won't go anymore.
He's just there for moral support.
I wasn't gonna...
Look!
We're so close!
We'll get there!
Where's my cursor?
Oh my god.
There's so much on this screen.
I can't even see my cursor at times.
Money?
Save?
We're saving!
It was 200!
Why are sometimes these so much faster?
Oh!
I just opened a new window!
Oh my gosh!
What the hell did I just open?
Oh!
I just opened the thing about Admiral C battles!
What did I miss?
Did I make it?
Did I win?
What was I doing?
I was gonna click some...
Oh!
I was gonna click this!
Hold on.
I gotta close out of this window.
Okay.
There we go.
Anyway...
Gosh!
Why do I have to take so much money?
Both of you!
No!
Unless... No!
I'm loyal.
I'm loyal to the mission.
But I... Oh my god!
No!
I
wish I had filmed myself getting to 183 before so I can remember what I did.
No!
Budget busted your game.
I know!
Why is it so hard to get money?
Man...
Need more farms?
Yeah!
But farms cost a lot of money!
Hey!
Stop spamming!
It's okay.
Like I said.
It's...
It's... It's...
What's the word?
Streaming...
Anxiety.
Performance anxiety!
No!
138!
Ewww!
We were so...
So far away from 200!
I tried...
I tried, you guys!
I'm not powerful enough!
I'll keep practicing.
I'll keep training.
And I'll...
I'll get it.
I'll get it next time.
If you had 140 to 138, that's way more than 200.
You're right!
You guys!
We did it!
We made it past 200!
Girl Math!
Yeah!
Yippee!
I don't want to use the free continue because...
I want to do it with a free continue.
Without you having to use the continue.
I want to do it without dying at all.
Loon6 is on the summer sale.
Yeah!
Have some of the money I saved.
Thanks Rowland!
Thank you!
Girl Math!
I feel like... What?
We only played what?
Two rounds?
But that means... Or two games rather.
But that means our rounds were good.
Because we got... We got far.
Because...
We played for a couple of hours.
What's this?
Oh yeah!
I got an achievement.
For destroying 5000 ZOMGs.
Ghost Math!
Yeah!
Two games in three hours is kind of...
Crazy.
Because it's not that much at all.
It's not that much at all.
Oh!
At three actually...
You're right.
No that was just a...
Don't worry about it.
Rounding error.
That even puts us...
Even higher above 200.
If you think about it.
So that makes us...
Basically at 300.
I think.
That's...
That's 318!
Yeah!
I might be the best.
That I ever was.
Sorry guys.
You can never...
You can only dream to get to my level.
If you factor in Ice Monkey it's at least 400.
So true.
Thanks for this fun stream.
Amazing job getting to round 300.
Thank you!
I would consider going longer.
But...
Since I have to get ready for my trip and stuff.
Umm...
I have some stuff to do.
I will end it here today.
200 or passed!
To be honest.
I'm a little frustrated.
Thanks for Bloons brain rot.
Just curious what anime you're looking forward to this month.
Nokotan and what?
Grandezer you.
You're gonna do what to me?
Nokotan.
I'll be honest.
I don't even know what's airing this month.
I'm behind on Blue Archive even.
I'm behind.
But I do want to watch Nokotan.
I'm interested in if it keeps...
You know how it has some of the...
Some...
Great marketing.
So I'm curious how the anime will be.
I hope it's like similar to Nichijou.
Shika no kono kono koko shi tan tan.
Wait.
Shikanoka no kanaka koshitan-tan!
Anyways, thank you guys!
I hope you guys had fun with Bloons.
As always, Bloons always brings out the crazy backseaters.
They're like, you guys are...
But it's fine, because I'm still learning, so it's okay.
What Bloons do you ship together?
All of my Sniper Monkeys.
Thanks for the stream, everybody!
It's my birthday!
Shionyus!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Shionyus!
Happy birthday!
Yeah, the Bloons community.
The Bloons community.
They're kind of crazy.
I'm just like, I'm just here to play monkey game.
And they're just like, more farms!
What are you doing?
I get it, I'm like trying to get to 200, but like...
But maybe we should calm down a little bit.
Why is the Ice Monkey on the chair?
Because that's where he belongs!
He's on vacation!
I need to match their energy.
If they start yelling at me, I need to yell back.
Why are you doing this?
Because I can!
BTD6 community is very emotionally invested.
So crazy.
It reminds me of like...
The...
The Cookie Run community.
I don't play Cookie Run, but I know that people get very serious about their cookies.
I don't understand.
What is it about baby games that makes people really crazy?
What is it?
Oh, you are a cookie now.
No!
Yeah, Cookie Run Kingdom.
That's what it's called, right?
Just play around with only Ice Monkey.
Baby games are serious business.
Do you think they get like this with like Candy Land and stuff?
Well, no.
I guess Candy Land is a little different.
There has to be an optimal way to play Candy Land.
Click the cookies.
Get out.
The monkeys are hotter?
And balloons?
Ice Monkey only stream.
Okay, we'll do Ice Monkey only next time.
Monkey business is serious business.
Next time we will 100%...
Well...
I'm not gonna guarantee that.
We will get to level 200.
We will do our best to get to level 200.
And we'll have an all Ice Monkey round.
Thanks for the fun stream.
Actually...
No.
I was gonna say, maybe I'll do it now.
But I gotta get my work done.
I gotta get my work done.
I was gonna do the Ice Monkey.
But it's okay.
Next time.
Awesome!
Oh, wait.
I see...
I think the donations...
The stream lab donos are kinda backed up.
So...
I see Ice Monkeys!
Thank you!
Ice Monkeys!
I juggle?
Thank you!
Try Princess!
Jessie, thank you!
Mentioned already.
Have you seen anything about the...
The VSMP Minecraft server?
A ton of different indie and small corporal VTubers play on it.
I'm sure you could get in.
If that would interest you.
I was actually invited to...
Not that.
But Barry invited me to a GTA RP server.
Which I've never done before.
So I'm a little nervous.
I don't wanna...
If I'm not invited to something though...
I don't wanna like...
Force my way in.
So...
But...
I have seen that some people have been playing on a...
On a...
V...
M...
No.
V...
S...
I can't say this word.
V...
S...
M...
P...
Server.
So...
But...
I don't know.
I don't think I'll ever stream the GTA one.
But...
Maybe if you see some people...
If you watch some indie VTubers...
And you see that they're streaming it...
I might be in there...
Someday.
I don't know.
VTuber survival multiplayer.
Is that what it stands for?
I never knew.
I've only ever...
The first time I ever heard about it was from...
Dream.
What is it?
The DS...
PM...?
No...
That's Deer Stage Perfect Music.
Oh!
SMP!
Sorry.
I don't know anything about Dream.
Get on the DSPM Minecraft server.
And Nan, thank you!
I see your anime recommendations, area 88.
Wait, that's old!
That's not new!
But thank you!
Oh wow, this duck, I just saw yours come in.
What you're saying is when Barry starts the server, we can expect a random cardboard box on the sidewalk from time to time?
Maybe!
If I have time.
She was like, no pressure!
And I was nervous because I've never done a server like that before.
I've never actually played GTA before either, so I'm just kind of like...
I don't know.
It's old, but it's good.
I hope you like it.
Thank you!
I don't know.
Nah, I've never played it.
If you guys are interested in me playing GTA...
I'll try it.
Because it looks fun.
I've never watched anyone play it before either because I...
was like, if I ever want to play it someday, I'll...
Not... I don't know.
Is that a game with spoilers?
I don't know anything about it, to be honest.
So...
Like single player?
Yeah, I guess so.
Yeah.
I don't know.
But anyway...
Reminds me of when you had GTA 5 on your final schedule a few years back.
All those years ago?
Why did I not do it?
I can't remember at all.
She's gonna run civilian over trust.
Yeah, probably.
Got a pretty good story mode?
No way, really?
Okay, cool.
Well guys, okay.
That's all tomorrow.
Finishing Metal Gear Solid 1.
And...
Yeah, I'm gonna go work on my stuff now.
I should have some like shorts that go up while I'm gone.
And also, if I can get this other video done, I'll have a special video.
A video that...
I'm kind of nervous about.
Because I've never put up this kind of video before.
So...
But...
Yeah.
I'm doing all the editing myself, so...
Anyway!
Anyway, anyway!
I will see you guys tomorrow.
And if not, I will see you guys the next time I catch you!
See you later!
Master!
Lady!
Bye bye!
Otsumita!
Thank you guys!
Thanks for watching!
Bye bye!